[Musique]
pour découvrir ce qui demain sera
peut-être une révolution il faut aller
au nord de l'Europe
c'est à l'intérieur des terres
au fin fond de la campagne irlandaise
que nous avons rendez-vous
derrière ces grilles derrière ces murs
un homme pense avoir trouvé une solution
à l'un des plus grands défis écologiques
aujourd'hui
une solution qui pourrait bouleverser
notre vie à tous
venez avec moi vous allez voir
princesse tout se passe par ici Michael
Murray est le propriétaire des lieux
une usine de 4000 mètres carrés qui a
priori ressemble à n'importe quel site
industriel
mais à y regarder de plus près nous
sommes bien dans un lieu à part
donc là dedans c'est votre mine d'or
alors
exactement une vraie mine d'or vous
allez voir ce que c'est derrière ces
immenses bâches voici la matière si
précieuse de Michael Murray du plastique
mais pas n'importe lequel il est vieux
il est sale il est puant bref une
marchandise bonne pour les poubelles
qu'est-ce qu'il y a ici
regardez ça c'est un vieux paquet de
chips
là c'est un vieux sachet de bacon
et tout ça ça vient des poubelles des
habitants exactement c'est ça
regardez
et ça c'est un vieil emballage de viande
des vieux emballages plastiques qui
d'ordinaire sont une véritable plaie
pour l'environnement car on ne peut rien
en faire
vous ce qui vous intéresse en fait ce
sont les plastiques non recyclables
exactement Michael Murray a ainsi décidé
de récupérer tous ces plastiques car il
a un moyen de les rendre très utile
20 tonnes de ces déchets ménagers
passent chaque jour par ses machines
pour subir une incroyable transformation
ils sont d'abord broyés en petite
lamelles
il passe ensuite par ses tuyaux pour
être chauffé au maximum
un processus extrêmement sensible qui
est surveillait en permanence sur
ordinateur
là vous voyez le plastique est chauffé
dans cette cuve à 400 degrés
l'idée c'est que ce plastique devienne
un gaz
et en fin de parcours à l'intérieur de
cette colonne ce gaz va encore se
transformer une dernière fois
à l'arrivée voilà ce qui en sort
un liquide brun un liquide dont les
vertus sont pour le moins inattendu car
les vieux déchets de plastique sont
maintenant devenus un produit
indispensable pour notre vie quotidienne
donc ça ce sont nos anciens podios en
quelque sorte
exactement
et ça ça va directement dans votre
voiture qu'est-ce que c'est du diesel
vous avez bien entendu du carburant à
base de plastique pour votre voiture
comment est-ce possible il y a à la base
le plastique c'est fait avec du pétrole
le plastique en quelque sorte au départ
c'est du pétrole donc on a trouvé le
moyen de remettre le plastique dans son
état d'origine de le retransformer en
pétrole
rien ne se perd rien ne se crée tout se
transforme
le diesel qui sort de cette usine et
consomment sur le champ
pas besoin de changer son réservoir
avec du plastique notre voiture marche
tout aussi bien
pour faire
rouleront nous tous un jour grâce à nos
vieux plastiques la question peut prêter
à sourire
et pourtant l'enjeu du recyclage de nos
produits est aujourd'hui crucial
car notre consommation d'un bout à
l'autre de la planète fonctionne de plus
en plus selon un même principe acheter
puis jeter un style de vie dont on ne
mesure pas toujours les conséquences sur
l'environnement
et pourtant
elles sont immenses
[Musique]
c'est le rythme de notre siècle celui de
notre planète tout entière
c'est notre rythme quotidien
[Musique]
produire acheter
nous sommes entrés dans l'ère de
l'hyperconsommation
[Musique]
New York bombel Londres Tokyo ou Paris
nous avons tous les mêmes envies à
satisfaire
toujours plus de vêtements toujours plus
de téléphone portable
de jouets ou des crampes là
une consommation signe de progrès et
d'innovation mais une consommation de
masse qui bouleverse de plus en plus
notre environnement
[Musique]
on achète et puis on jette ce n'est plus
possible
voilà le point de départ de cette
enquête à travers le monde bonjour nous
avons voulu comprendre quel impact notre
consommation chez nous peut avoir à
l'autre bout du globe
avant il y avait de l'eau ici alors
quand j'étais petite il y avait de l'eau
partout maintenant il y a plus rien
nous avons cherché à savoir pourquoi
puiser sans relâche dans les ressources
de notre planète peut perturber la vie
de population tout entière
ça c'est de la capacité rite et tout le
monde se bat pour en avoir
face à ses défis nous avons rencontré
ceux qui cherchent des alternatives au
jour le jour pour consommer autrement
si j'ai le choix entre plusieurs
produits je prends toujours celui avec
un plus pour l'environnement
c'est ma façon de faire un geste pour la
planète
un voyage qui nous a conduit là ou
s'invente les nouvelles solutions et les
produits écologiques de demain
[Musique]
c'est pas le temps et voilà le prototype
du jean en ortie
ni aucune différence au toucher ça
ressemble à un jean normal sauf que là
il y a de l'ortie dedans
du Congo à l'Italie de la France
jusqu'au fin fond de la Chine
nous sommes partis en enquête pour
répondre à une question qui nous
concerne tous
comment continuer à consommer tout ce
que nous voulons sans pour autant
plier la planète
[Musique]
notre film commence au coeur de Paris
sur les Champs-Elysées une avenue ou
beaucoup aiment faire du shopping c'est
le cas par exemple dans et Daniel
plusieurs fois par mois mère et fille
s'offre une virée dans les temples de la
fringues pas cher
au programme des achats de vêtements
juste pour le plaisir
il y a toujours cette envie de nouveau
de changer il y a pas il y a pas
vraiment de besoin mais l'envie
ça
pour assouvir ses envies le magasin lui
offre un choix pléthorique les vêtements
samassent
de toutes les formes et de toutes les
couleurs
le tout a des prix très attractifs ici
tout est pensé pour pousser à la
consommation
[Musique]
en tout cas je me lâche en disant c'est
pas grave ça dure juste la saison et
puis hop j'en change et voilà et comme
toute façon le piège c'est que tu viens
toutes les semaines et toutes les
semaines il y a des nouveaux articles
toute façon c'est horrible
des collections qui changent de plus en
plus souvent et qui privilégie toujours
la même matière le coton
80% des habits vendus dans nos magasins
sont fabriqués avec du coton
il suffit de regarder les étiquettes il
domine tous les rayons
on le retrouve partout aujourd'hui un
vêtement sur deux vendu dans le monde
est en coton
une suprématie qui est loin d'être
anodine
[Musique]
ce que nous allons découvrir c'est que
pour satisfaire notre consommation de
vêtements en coton notre environnement
et bouleversé
pour le comprendre nous partons chez le
plus gros producteur de coton au monde
à des milliers de kilomètres de la
France
en Chine
au nord-ouest du pays dans une province
située entre la Mongolie et le
Kazakhstan le signe
[Musique]
le Cynthia Yang c'est la région la plus
reculée du pays ici nous sommes sur
l'ancienne route de la soie
loin des gratte-ciels de la Chine
moderne le cynthiang est une province
rurale peuplée de 20 millions
d'habitants
[Musique]
une mosaïque ethnique composée de
peuples venus d'Asie centrale
d'anciens nomades berger et pêcheurs
occasionnels
mais ce qui frappe surtout lorsque l'on
s'enfonce dans la campagne
ce sont ces tracteurs surchargés
il transporte des dizaines de sacs de
coton
[Musique]
se dirigent vers des usines en bord de
route comme celle-ci
chaque jour ils viennent décharger leur
blanc de toute une région
[Musique]
à lui seul le cynthiaang produit 40 % du
coton chinois
entre les routes et les dunes les champs
se succèdent sur des dizaines de
kilomètres
[Musique]
des milliers d'hectares d'une petite
fleur fragile qui fait travailler toute
une province
[Musique]
pour nous en rendre compte notre enquête
nous mène dans l'une des centaines
d'exploitations de la région
150 hectares une ferme de taille moyenne
ici qui ne paye pas de mine
[Musique]
c'est un ancien bâtiment d'État aux murs
décrépi que le gouvernement chinois a
privatisé il y a une dizaine d'années
et celui qui a repris l'affaire bonjour
Merci bonjour c'est votre service c'est
quoi vous êtes chez moi ici un ex
ouvrier agricole tous les ouvriers
tu vois les portes là-bas c'est là
qu'ils habitent le soir
ici cette année j'en ai 120 ouvriers
et là en ce moment ils sont au champ là
ils sont en train de ramasser
que trois mois pour faire ramasser tout
son coton
alors il faut aller vite avant l'arrivée
des grands froids
pour faire cette récolte dans les temps
une armada travailleur saisonniers est à
pied d'oeuvre tous sont ici pour
cueillir la fleur qui est à l'origine de
nos vêtements
parmi eux à aider
vient du sudch One une province très
pauvre a des milliers de kilomètres
d'ici au centre du pays au moment de
notre rencontre cela fait déjà 5 heures
qu'il récolte la fleur de coton dans son
sac de toile une récolte qui se fait à
la main un travail qui demande une
dextérité particulière pour transformer
ses doigts en de véritables machines
Carla de ce monsieur se tient au début
je le ramassais comme ça moi juste en
tirant
à ramasser le coton en un seul geste ça
demande une certaine pratique tu sais
tout en même temps
et c'est très difficile
mais non regarde il faut ouvrir la fleur
avant de tirer comme ça
voilà donc au départ à quoi ressemble le
coton de nos vêtements des plans de
moins d'un mètre de haut sur lesquels se
développe plusieurs capsules
lorsqu'elles s'ouvre elle laisse
s'échapper de petites touffes blanches
quelques grammes à peine à chaque fois
toute la journée à aider louer les
autres ramasseurs se plie en deux pour
récolter la précieuse matière première
de nos vêtements
et ce n'est qu'à la nuit tombée que tous
les ouvriers sont de retour à la ferme
il est 22 heures
alors
et les autres acheminent leur sac
jusqu'à la pesée aujourd'hui il
accueilli 80 kilos
et c'est bien ça ou pas c'est une bonne
journée ou pas
je suis pas totalement satisfait car on
voudrait toujours cueillir le plus
possible mais 80 kilos c'est bien
soit un salaire de 11 euros pour 12h de
travail c'est en moyenne ce que ces
ouvriers gagnent en une journée
grâce à ses ramasseurs cette province
est ainsi devenue la première région
productrice de coton au monde
partout dans le cimetière tourne autour
du coton on le cultive on le transforme
le coton brut est traité sur place pour
obtenir la fibre qui se retrouvera dans
la plupart de nos vêtements cette année
plus de 3 millions de tonnes ont été
produites
cette région assure à elle seule 15% de
la production mondiale et pourtant cette
culture
omniprésente qui paraît naturelle est en
fait le fruit de la volonté d'un seul
homme une histoire qui a commencé il y a
50 ans
nous sommes dans les années 60 à
l'époque Mao le leader de la Chine
communiste décide de développer
l'industrie du coton pour cela il a
besoin de main d'oeuvre et surtout de
vastes espaces
le parti envoie alors des milliers de
Chinois de l'Est coloniser le nord-ouest
le cynthiang est une terre idéale selon
Pékin la région est immense ensoleillée
et surtout très peuplé
[Musique]
mais le cimetiang est une terre aride
une zone désertique que rien ne
prédestinée au départ à la culture du
coton
or le problème c'est que le coton est
l'une des plantes les plus gourmandes en
eau
pour produire un kilo de coton il faut
11000 litres d'eau en moyenne une
quantité considérable qui représente la
consommation d'un Français pendant trois
mois
[Musique]
les nouveaux arrivants se lancent alors
dans des travaux titanesques
il creuse des canaux
baptisent des réservoirs et des systèmes
de Vannes pour irriguer les champs
il décide en fait de pomper dans la
seule ressource en eau de la région le
fleuve
50 ans plus tard le paysage est
quadrillé par ses canaux qui s'étendent
sur des centaines de kilomètres
des canaux que l'on utilise aujourd'hui
encore pour irriguer tous les champs
comme ceux de Gwen
le patron de cette exploitation a vu le
paysage se modifier pour permettre la
culture intensive du coton pour nous ça
nous paraît presque fou de pouvoir faire
pousser une plante comme le coton sur
une terre qui est aussi sèche que
celle-là quoi ça paraît un peu
la neige fondue
et surtout l'eau de la rivière qui vient
par les canaux
pour acheminer de l'eau jusque dans ses
champs il a installé un système de tuyau
qui court le long des allées l'eau vient
de la rivière voisine et irrigue en
permanence chaque plan un système de
pompage qui épuise les cours d'eau à
certaines périodes de l'année
et il y en a encore de l'eau dans la
rivière
en ce moment il va falloir attendre il
n'y en aura qu'en hiver
Gwan est loin d'être le seul tous les
fermiers de la région ont fait comme lui
une agriculture intensive qui a pompé
pendant des années les ressources en eau
résultat un peu partout on croise ces
lits rivières à sécher où l'on devine la
hauteur des au passé
car en 50 ans le bassin du Tarim s'est
profondément transformé
après des années de surexploitation le
fleuve s'est réduit
[Musique]
à l'est le bras qui alimentait le lac
lobe Nour c'est asséché entraînant la
disparition du lac
[Musique]
au sud le lac tahithéma a été réduit de
moitié
partout l'eau se fait plus rare
[Musique]
alors pour faire face à cette pénurie
Gwen Rui a décidé d'employer les grands
moyens pomper dans le sous-sol
directement dans les nappes phréatiques
il a creusé depuis comme celui-ci
tu vois ça c'est le compteur électrique
il y a un câble qui va jusqu'au moteur
ici
et quand on le met en route ça va pomper
l'eau et hop ça part là-bas
vers les champs
vous allez puiser jusqu'à combien au
fond là
il faut creuser jusqu'à 80 mètres pour
pouvoir bien pomper
sinon on n'est pas sûr d'avoir assez
d'eau et il y a 5 ans par exemple il
fallait aussi aller à 80 mètres ou pas
non avant on creusait à 30 mètres
maximum mais si on continue à cultiver
le coton là comme ça bientôt il y en
aura plus d'eau dans le puits
le niveau continuera de baisser c'est
sûr
mais c'est pas un problème ça plutôt
d'argent
pour ça
mais je ne gagnerai jamais autant
d'argent
le coton ça rapporte beaucoup tu sais
gagne 1300 euros par mois c'est 20 fois
plus que le salaire minimum
alors évidemment ici personne ne songe à
s'arrêter
et pourtant dans la région
l'exploitation de l'or blanc n'en finit
pas de faire des dégâts des dégâts
écologiques et bien plus encore
partout au cours de notre voyage nous
croisons des restes de forêt
complètement desséchés
une transformation du paysage qui a
bouleversé l'existence de milliers de
personnes
comme à yengisu par exemple un village
de berger quasiment abandonné au bord de
la route
il y a encore cinq ans plus de 300
personnes vivaient ici aujourd'hui il
reste 5 familles
emragoon habite là depuis 40 ans avec
les siens selon elle c'est le coton qui
a volé leur vie d'avant
avant il y avait de l'eau ici alors oui
quand j'étais petit il y avait de l'eau
partout maintenant il y a plus rien il y
avait une petite rivière là ici oui
et cela crée des petits étangs des
petites mains naturels et il y avait des
puits difficile de s'en rendre compte
aujourd'hui mais il y a encore quelques
années l'eau courait entre les arbres et
le paysage était entièrement vert
en tout cas vous pouvez pas utiliser
cette nature pour faire vivre vos bêtes
très très loin
impossible de faire paître les troupes
ici les frères dem ragoon sont donc
parti avec les bêtes et elle et sa mère
se débrouille comme elles peuvent avec
les enfants
le petit dernier à 6 mois
vous vivez de quoi
en fait on élève des moutons
et on les vend pour s'acheter des
céréales
du maïs et même des melons mais comment
vous faites pour vous nourrir comment
vous arrivez à survivre quand on a
vraiment plus rien à manger on est
obligé de se débrouiller et d'aller
chercher du travail un peu plus loin
ce village est loin d'être un cas isolé
il y en a des dizaines dans la même
situation
et désormais les autorités chinoises
commencent à s'inquiéter
ce que redoute le gouvernement c'est que
la Chine ne subisse le même sort avec la
culture du coton que celui qui a connu
un pays voisin
[Musique]
à quelques centaines de kilomètres du
cimetière
bienvenue en Ouzbékistan
un pays qui s'est lancé lui aussi dans
une production massive de coton 20 ans
avant la Chine aujourd'hui les
conséquences sont irréversibles
seuls les bateaux rouillés rappelle
qu'il y a peu encore cette terre était
en fait une mer la mer d'Aral
à force de puiser dans les réserves en
eau du pays voilà ce qui s'est passé
dans les années 70 la mère était grande
comme deux fois la Belgique
depuis elle s'est inexorablement vidée
pour permettre au coton lui de fleurir
en masse
[Musique]
des problèmes d'assèchement qui risquent
de se multiplier à travers le monde car
jamais la demande de coton n'a été aussi
forte
un peu partout la production s'emballe
plus d'une centaine de pays en
produisent désormais à travers le monde
[Musique]
Ouzbékistan Chine mais aussi Inde
Pakistan pays africains Australie
Turquie Brésil États-Unis en 50 ans la
production mondiale a quasiment triplé
et dans chacun de ces pays l'eau est
surexploité
pourtant la fièvre acheteuse des
consommateurs du monde entier ne
semblent pas fléchir on achète puis on
jette souvent au-delà de nos besoins et
parmi tous nos vêtements il y en a un
qui est devenu un uniforme mondial un
qui symbolise à lui seul cet hiver
consommation de coton ambre notre fan de
shopping en sait quelque chose
alors là on va les compter
1 2 3 ce vêtement c'est évidemment le
jean 12
elle en a 13 une véritable collection et
autant de mode qui passe et qui passe
il y a eu le slim le bootcut le tie-base
le taille haute un plus foncé un plus
clair parfois même en deux exemplaires
mais c'est juste pour avoir un nouveau
Jean un nouveau pantalon pour agrandir
la garde-robe dans la maison familiale
personne n'y échappe la fille donc mais
aussi la mère et le père tout le monde a
depuis longtemps succombé à la mode du
Blue Jeans
[Musique]
vous avez combien de jeans pour toute la
famille 25
Gilles vous imaginiez que vous en aviez
autant dans les armoires
pourtant rien de très étonnant les
consommateurs français achètent trois
nouveaux jeans par an en moyenne deux
fois plus qu'il y a 10 ans
lors de notre enquête nous nous sommes
donc rendus dans le lieu où sont
fabriqués la plupart de nos jeans
nous sommes en Chine du Sud à côté de
canton dans la ville de xingtong que
l'on surnomme
[Musique]
ici un habitant sur quatre travaille
dans l'industrie du jean
il y a des dizaines de petits ateliers à
chaque coin de rue où tout est réalisé à
la main
et puis dimanche usines où tout le
processus est industrialisé
plus de 100 000 ouvriers sont dédiés à
la fabrication de ce pantalon a priori
une production à la chaîne classique en
Chine
découpage du coton couture finition
assemblage
au total 40% des jeans fabriqués à
xingtong sont vendus dans le reste du
monde et notamment chez nous
mais derrière ce succès économique se
cache une autre réalité
beaucoup moins glorieuse car ce que nous
allons découvrir c'est que la
fabrication de ce pantalon entraîne un
scandale écologique
nous allons nous en rendre compte lors
d'une étape cruciale de la production du
textile celle de la teinture du coton en
bleu la couleur dominante du jean
un processus totalement secret aucune
usine de teinture n'a voulu nous ouvrir
ses portes
c'est donc muni d'une caméra cachée que
nous nous rendons dans l'une d'elles une
teinturerie clandestine comme il en
existe des dizaines en ville
pour ne pas alerter les ouvriers nous ne
dévoilons pas notre identité
qui êtes-vous qu'est-ce que vous faites
ici
c'est un artiste peintre il fait un
voyage en Chine et il voudrait voir les
teintures pour son travail
et bien on a différentes couleurs blanc
bleu ou mixte
[Musique]
au départ le fil de coton arrive blanc
sur ses bobines puis les ouvriers les
places à l'étage dans une étuve dans
laquelle il verse de la teinture de
l'eau et toute une série de produits
chimiques toxiques pour fixer la couleur
bleue
cuve et on chauffe le coton dans la cuve
c'est ça avec la teinture oui c'est ça
pendant combien de temps
une à deux heures
une fois teinte les bobines de fil sont
essorés dans cette centrifugeuse le
surplus d'eau de teinture s'écoule dans
ce bac
[Musique]
et ensuite l'eau elle va où elle va dans
la rivière
va dans les égouts
qui ensuite va dans la rivière
ouais ça repart dans les égouts la
rivière les champs en fait on sait pas
très bien où ça va
en réalité cette eau de teinture ce
cocktail de produits chimiques se
retrouvent directement dans la nature
ni traitement des eaux ni recyclage des
dizaines d'usines ont les mêmes
pratiques laissant comme des taches
d'huile à la surface
les eaux qui signent la ville sont
littéralement bleu marine voire noir
ici à l'arrière de cette teinturerie les
rives portent même encore les traces des
déversements sauvages
et vu du ciel c'est encore plus
spectaculaire
ici ce bras de fleuve est noir
le problème c'est que cette pollution
n'est pas que visuelle elle a aussi des
conséquences sur la santé
c'est le constat qu'a fait cette étude
de Greenpeace réaliser l'année dernière
dans la région
des chercheurs ont prélevé de l'eau à
proximité d'une grande teinturerie
et voici ce qu'ils ont trouvé
des concentrations de produits chimiques
chaque fois au-delà des limites
autorisées
du manganèse par exemple
une surexposition à ce métal lourd peut
entraîner de nombreux dommages sur le
cerveau
[Musique]
des algues phénols ces perturbateurs
endocriniens peuvent réduire la
fertilité
dans les campagnes proches de ses usines
les villageois n'ont pas eu besoin
d'études scientifiques pour voir que
leur environnement avait changé
plus de poissons plus d'eau pur dans les
rivières et beaucoup s'alarent de cette
pollution
pourtant lorsqu'on discute avec eux le
discours est étonnant et donc la vie
c'était mieux avant ou c'est mieux
aujourd'hui c'est mieux maintenant
on a de l'argent chaque année
on peut acheter tout ce qu'on veut
c'était pas le cas avant
mais votre environnement est pollué bien
sûr je suis un peu triste si on ne
produisait pas autant de jeans notre
environnement serait propre mais que
voulez-vous si nous n'en faisons pas ce
sont les autres qui le feront
l'industrie du jean et la culture du
coton sont donc particulièrement
polluantes et pose un problème à notre
planète et pourtant difficile d'imaginer
qu'on puisse s'en passer à travers le
monde 50 millions de personnes vivent de
l'industrie de ce textile
malgré tout certains se lancent
aujourd'hui dans la quête d'alternative
au coton comme le lin le chanvre ou le
coton bio un coton sans pesticides qui
ne pollue pas l'eau et les sols mais
l'une des solutions les plus
surprenantes à nos yeux
[Musique]
se trouve au nord de l'Europe
nous voici au Pays-Bas à deux heures de
route d'Amsterdam en pleine campagne
c'est ici que la marque brenel a décidé
de présenter ses collections
la marque privilégie le lin le chanvre
la laine ou le coton bio mais depuis
deux ans maintenant une nouvelle matière
est entrée dans la composition de
certains produits
tout à fait
de l'ortie on en retrouve dans des
pantalons des pulls et même des robes
7 clientes c'est laisser convaincre
et comment vous sentez-vous bien
vraiment oui oui c'est très confortable
ça ne gratte pas je ne vois pas de
différence avec d'autres matières
l'Urtica elle ressemble à l'ortie que
nous connaissons tous celle qui démange
mais celle-ci ne pique pas elle est
cultivée on la plante puis on la récolte
chaque année au mois d'août
l'avantage c'est que cette plante n'a
pas besoin d'irrigation et peut pousser
partout en Europe
la matière que l'on va utiliser
ressemble à de gros ballots de foin
pour obtenir du fil d'ortie il faut que
la plante passe dans ces machines
[Musique]
elle aide à Thema ingénieur textile
travaille sur le développement de
l'ortie depuis 5 ans ces machines lui
permettent d'obtenir de la fibre prête à
l'emploi en moins de 10 minutes
et voilà le résultat à la fin de la
chaîne
regardez il n'y a plus que la fibre de
l'ortie transformée en textile
une fois filet ces fibres donnent une
matière fine très isolante et quasiment
aussi solide que le coton
le siège de la marque est à quelques
mètres à peine des champs
bonjour l'équipe compte une quinzaine de
personnes toutes convaincue du potentiel
de cette aire
c'est les nouveaux échantillons
ils viennent d'arriver
hélène est accompagnée de Yen un ancien
ingénieur de Nike qui a lâché le géant
américain pour se lancer dans cette
aventure depuis quelques mois il
multiplie les essais pour obtenir plus
de formes de couleurs indispensables
pour être crédible face au coton et pour
conquérir le grand public quoi de mieux
qu'un jean
star
aucune différence au toucher
par exemple
ça ressemble à un jean normal sauf que
là il y a de l'ortie dedans 12% d'orties
mélangées avec du coton bio
l'aboutissement de trois ans de
recherche reste le prix tout de même le
jean sera vendu à New York l'équivalent
de 230 euros car aujourd'hui l'ortie est
encore quatre fois plus cher que le
coton mais plus la demander la
production augmenteront plus les coûts
devraient baisser
[Musique]
il serait donc possible de produire les
jeans autrement en polluant un enjeu
auquel le citoyen est de plus en plus
sensible
un enjeu qui concerne aujourd'hui tous
les produits que nous achetons mais
voilà avec les modes qui changent
toujours plus vite et des prix toujours
plus bas on est poussé en permanence à
consommer mais aussi à jeter
80% des produits que nous achetons
partent à la poubelle après une seule
utilisation
[Musique]
nous sommes entrés dans l'ère du jetable
et parmi tous les produits dont on se
débarrasse il y en a un qui commence à
poser un problème majeur à notre
environnement au départ il s'agissait
pourtant d'une invention qui a
littéralement changé
notre quotidien
juste un mot
plastique il y a de l'avenir dans les
plastiques
son zizi le plastique dans les années 60
c'est la nouvelle matière à la mode
un matériau qui est le fruit de
l'imagination d'un chercheur génial au
début du 20e siècle
en 1917 Léo backland un chimiste belge
installé aux États-Unis invente une
résine à base de pétrole à laquelle il
donne son nom la bakélite
une nouvelle matière qui ne font pas
sous l'effet de la flamme elle est
robuste
[Musique]
mais c'est après la deuxième guerre
mondiale qu'on entre vraiment dans l'ère
du plastique la place conquise par les
plastiques sur le marché va
s'élargissant chaque jour
les années 50 marque les débuts de la
consommation de masse c'est le triomphe
du plastique
vaisselle récipient mobilier tout
devient plastique
fini le laitier avec ces bouteilles de
verre fini les petits potes cartons pour
les yaourts les emballages plastiques
sont nés on les jette après usage la
presse célèbre l'ère du tout jetable une
marque américaine symbolise à elle seule
l'essor du plastique dans la cuisine
[Musique]
qui va permettre à des millions de
ménagères à travers le monde de
conserver les aliments et de consommer
différemment grâce au plastique
et là c'est vraiment un tupperware cette
fois-ci vous pouvez le mettre dans un
sac à main vous pouvez le retourner dans
un réfrigérateur ça ne fuira jamais et
aujourd'hui il suffit de se rendre au
domicile de n'importe quelle famille on
va ranger toutes les affaires donc vous
m'aidez
dans chaque recoin de la maison
dans la cuisine bien sûr
mais aussi dans la salle de bain
[Musique]
ou encore dans la chambre des enfants
le souci c'est qu'aujourd'hui on ne sait
plus quoi en faire car lorsqu'on le met
à la poubelle voilà ce qui se passe
20% seulement sera récupéré pour être
transformé en nouveaux objets comme par
exemple des arrosoirs ou des stylos pour
les plastiques non recyclés il existe
bien des solutions qui se mettent en
place comme par exemple celle que nous
avons vu dans l'usine irlandaise qui
transforme ses déchets en carburant
mais pour la plupart des plastiques leur
fin de vie pose problème
[Musique]
il y a ceux qui sont incinérés
ceux qui sont enterrés dans les
décharges
mais le principal danger pour notre
environnement ce sont les milliers les
millions de déchets plastiques
abandonnés et qui mettront des siècles à
disparaître
car si un mouchoir en papier met trois
mois se désagréger dans la nature et une
canette en aluminium 80 ans un sac en
plastique lui mettra 500 ans et une
bouteille d'eau 1000 ans
et l'endroit où la pollution par ses
plastiques abandonnés est la plus
dramatique c'est la mer
et ce n'est pas la peine d'aller très
loin pour le constater
nous sommes à Marseille Benjamin a
rendez-vous avec des copains pour une
grande opération de sauvetage comment ça
va
salut le sauvetage de la plage
l'endroit a beau être régulièrement
nettoyé par les services de la Ville
lorsqu'on y regarde de près il y a
encore beaucoup de travail
perdu pendant une baignade
les pailles et tout ça ça c'est très ça
flotte ça flotte beaucoup donc au caca
on les retrouve très facilement sur sur
les plages
bouchon sac jouet abandonné on trouve
toutes sortes de déchets et c'est
justement contre cela que se battre
Benjamin et ses copains ils sont membres
de soft rider Foundation une ONG qui
œuvre à la protection du littoral
il y a 80% en fait des déchets qu'on
peut trouver sur une plage qui n'ont pas
été déposés sur la plage à même la plage
mais qui ont transité par l'océan ces
militants écolos vont ramasser ainsi
toutes sortes de détritus plastique et à
l'arrivée voici l'ampleur des dégâts
du coup
cinq ramassage d'une heure un mètre cube
et demi de déchets mais Benjamin le sait
dans quelques semaines il va devoir
revenir sur cette plage pour la même
opération car c'est une réalité la mère
est très polluée par nos déchets
pour cent des plastiques produits chaque
année finirez ainsi leur vie au fond des
océans
[Musique]
des plastiques qui viennent tous de la
terre comme cette bouteille abandonnée
après un pique-nique
transporté par les cours d'eau
elle va finir par atteindre la mer
où elle ira rejoindre des millions
d'autres détritus aussi perdus dans
l'océan
tous ces déchets vont se morceler se
fragmenter
leur concentration peut atteindre des
tailles considérables
ainsi au milieu du Pacifique la masse de
plastique qui s'est formée est déjà
grande comme une fois et demi la France
et ce n'est pas la seule zone la plupart
des mers du globe sont concernés comme
l'océan Atlantique ou la Méditerranée
et vous allez voir que cette pollution
extrêmement insidieuse peut avoir des
conséquences sur notre vie à tous
au nord de la Corse près de la citadelle
de Calvi une base marine en béton
dissimulée dans les rochers
l'endroit n'a rien d'un bunker ultra
secret nous sommes en fait dans le
repère d'une poignée de scientifiques
François gallgani et chercheur à
l'Ifremer l'institut spécialisé dans les
recherches
océanographiques cet universitaire
étudie les déchets plastiques qui
flottent dans nos océans
à quelques centaines de mètres des côtes
l'expérience va commencer
encore aucune industrie polluante aucune
agriculture intensive ces rivage devrait
donc être épargné
et pourtant lorsque le scientifique
jette un œil à la surface les premières
tâches apparaissent
des morceaux de plastique qui en réalité
remonte du fond de la mer le chercheur
s'en est rendu compte en filmant les
gros déchets déposés au fond de la
Méditerranée
des sacs des gobelets des bouteilles qui
s'accumulent parfois jusqu'à 1000 mètres
de profondeur au large de Nice ou de
Marseille
avec le temps ces déchets se fragmentent
lentement mais ne disparaissent jamais
à bord du bateau Annabelle la
spécialiste du plancton jette le filet
qui sert d'ordinaire à ramasser les
micro-organismes marins
pendant 20 minutes le filet va se
charger mais pas seulement en plancton
qui est qui bouge en surface
de quelques morceaux de plastique avec
le plancton qui se déplace le plancton
est bien visible mais dans cette eau un
peu trouble on distingue autre chose des
dépôts plastiques c'est ça que le
chercheur veut analyser
on s'est aperçu que ça se dégradait et
que donc elle avait partout et là on
commence maintenant justement adresser
un inventaire et savoir essayer de
comprendre comment ça pourrait circule
et où est-ce qu'ils vont s'accumuler et
comment ils vont se dégrader alors pour
étudier tout cela direction le
laboratoire
bonjour bonjour ça va une fois filtré
les échantillons révèlent d'importantes
quantités de plastique
voilà ce que ça donne après on a des
morceaux de polystyrène à des morceaux
de plastique donc différentes couleurs
vous voyez c'est de la fragmentation de
la fragmentation de d'emballage qui sont
beaucoup de plus grosses tailles quoi
selon les calculs de ce chercheur la
Méditerranée contaminée par 250
milliards de fragments de plastique
le problème lorsque le plastique
colonise la mer c'est qu'il entre
également dans la chaîne alimentaire
c'est l'inquiétude du biologiste
Jean-Henri Heck c'est particulier le
plastique sont à gérer par le plancton
et par les mêmes organismes du plancton
et quand ils sont dans l'estomac c'est
des conditions
extrêmement brutale de digestion comme
dans notre estomac c'est bourré d'acide
et donc ces plastiques peuvent être
dégradés et là nous ne connaissons pas
encore bien les les dégâts que ça peut
ça peut donner
car ces fragments de plastique sont
avalés par de petits poissons appelés
mythophydées ces poissons sont la base
de l'alimentation des gros poissons
laiton ou les dorades que l'homme va
pêcher à son tour et qui finiront dans
notre assiette
ainsi nous avalons du plastique mais
dans notre estomac ces plastiques
relâchent-ils des polluants quels sont
les conséquences pour notre santé les
études ne font que commencer les
scientifiques n'ont pas encore toutes
les réponses
mais François et ses collègues le
constatent tous les jours le plastique a
envahi notre environnement car on en
produit toujours davantage trois fois
plus qu'il y a 20 ans et il y a un
endroit dans notre quotidien où c'est
particulièrement frappant
cet endroit ce sont les rayons des
grandes surfaces le royaume des
emballages
eau minéral
produit ménagers ou encore produits
high-tech les emballages se superposent
les uns aux autres ils changent en
permanence de forme de taille ou de
couleur
ces plastiques sont difficilement
recyclables et pourtant les industriels
en mettent sur un grand nombre de leurs
produits des emballages qui vous allez
le voir sont conçus pour avoir le
maximum d'impact sur notre consommation
[Musique]
dans les beaux quartiers de la capitale
un hôtel particulier dans le 16e
arrondissement
nous voici chez pulp agence de design
ces graphistes sont spécialisés dans la
conception d'emballage ici sur
ordinateur on invente la forme arrondie
de votre yaourt
là on dessine le relief en haut de votre
bouteille d'eau
tous les deux ans les marques leur
demandent de créer de nouveaux
emballages pour séduire toujours plus le
client
et pour cela les équipes d'Anna Anderson
la directrice de création mettre le
plastique à toutes les sauces
par exemple avec le Sliver cette espèce
de collant en plastique qui sert à
habiller le produit pour le rendre
encore plus visible dans les rayons
c'est juste un film plastique qui est
posé sur la bouteille le slivan nous
permet de d'aller écrire partout faire
du graphisme sur toute la surface
c'est de cette façon que les marques se
sont mises à ajouter une nouvelle couche
de plastique sur le plastique ou le vert
de la bouteille
l'autre nouveauté dans les rayonnages ce
sont ses poches souples en plastique
elle remplace les bouteilles en verre
pour les sauces les petits pots pour la
compote ou ici la boîte cartonnée pour
le thé
nous on arrive avec un volume silhouette
donc on a vraiment une histoire qui est
racontée via la forme et du coup ça nous
donne de l'impact et on est vu plus de
visibilité
tout simplement plus de visibilité c'est
donc bon pour les industriels mais
est-ce vraiment utile à notre
consommation
nous partons à la rencontre de quelqu'un
qui en doute fortement il se trouve en
Alsace il n'a rien d'un militant écolo
son intérêt dans la vie c'est même de
nous vendre un maximum de produits
à 25 km de Mulhouse il dirige ce
supermarché
bonjour monsieur
alors donc c'est la chasse au plastique
la Bruno mon droyant gère ce supermarché
depuis 17 ans et depuis le début il y a
une chose qui l'agace le sur emballage
en premier lieu dans un rayon les jouets
est-ce qu'il est franchement nécessaire
d'avoir une telle volumétrie en termes
de packaging en termes de Pâques compte
tenu des produits qui sont à l'intérieur
pour être très bien être limité en
termes de volume pour permettre moins de
plastique et moins de cartons pour nous
le prouver Bruno va faire une petite
expérience alors je vais vous montrer
qu'en fait le produit pourrait très bien
vivre sans la partie plastique avec
uniquement en fait le
le carton
et que le produit serait complètement
commercialisable sans souci
c'est à dire
et ça
on élimine
plus de plastique que du carton ouais
mais alors j'imagine que pour le
transport ça serait beaucoup plus
fragile les produits sont attachés au
niveau du carton donc il y a pas de
souci donc la fenêtre Pour être très
bien être éliminé cette fenêtre là cette
fenêtre là en l'occurrence d'accord
ça va directement je dirais en
déchetterie et ces plastiques dont on
pourrait se passer selon lui il y en a
partout au rayon dentifrice et hop une
plastique mais aussi aux produits
d'entretien aux fruits et légumes ou
encore au rayon fromage
ici on trouve de plus en plus de
morceaux emballés dans des barquettes et
des fils non recyclables un système peut
être pratique pour les clients mais un
vrai gâchis pour l'environnement il y a
pourtant un moyen très simple d'éviter
ce sur emballage
demander à ma serveuse de me servir un
morceau de mascarpone qu'elle va
m'emballer traditionnellement dans une
feuille de papier donc on éviterait
effectivement bah la barquette elle
filme et ça coûte exactement le même
prix
mais Bruno ne se contente pas de
dénoncer cette invasion de plastique
pour éviter que tous ces emballages ne
se retrouvent dans la nature il a
installé des bacs à la sortie de son
magasin
et les clients des emballent et me
laisse le plastique d'un côté et le
carton de l'autre
et ce plastique ce plastique vous allez
le mettre dans le box plastique des
emballages collectés que Bruno va
confier directement à des centres de
recyclage
des initiatives comme celle-ci se
multiplient de plus en plus en France
mais on pourrait aller beaucoup plus
loin car tout près de chez nous certains
ont déjà inventé ce qui pourrait
peut-être un jour remplacer le plastique
de l'autre côté des Alpes une petite
ville d'Italie du Nord Est au cœur d'une
révolution verte
nous arrivons à Novara près de Milan une
ville de 100.000 habitants
direction le centre-ville
enchanté
Claudia césa et sa maman ont l'habitude
de faire leurs courses ensemble depuis
quelques temps elles ont décidé de
changer leur façon de consommer
bon d'abord on va aller au rayon des
produits d'entretien
comme tout le monde elles font leurs
courses au supermarché du coin un
supermarché
identique à ce qu'il y a en France à
première vue sauf qu'ici on trouve des
produits différents cette essuie-tout
par exemple
et bien ils sont particuliers parce
qu'ils sont emballés avec une matière
qui s'appelle le materby oui c'est écrit
là
c'est un emballage complètement végétal
et si j'ai le choix entre plusieurs
produits je prends toujours celui avec
un plus pour l'environnement c'est ma
façon de faire un geste pour la planète
des emballages en plastique végétal on
en trouve des dizaines dans cette grande
surface comme ceux de ces mouchoirs ou
de ses serviettes hygiéniques
mais il y a aussi des produits
entièrement en bio plastiques comme ces
cotons-tiges ou ses sacs poubelles
totalement biodégradables
ça veut dire que quand vous jetterez ces
sacs et bien il se retrouveront dans la
nature en gros et ce dégraderont oui
avec le temps ils vont se dégrader se
désagréger
ces articles font donc désormais partie
du quotidien de Claudia des produits
derrière lesquels se cachent en fait
l'histoire de quelques chercheurs qui
ont imaginé avant tout le monde une
planète sans déchets plastiques
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres de Novara se
trouve le lieu où cette révolution écolo
a commencé
novamons le leader mondial des
bioplastiques
Katia bastioli
alors c'est votre univers ici oui c'est
vraiment ma maison c'est carrément ma
maison c'est le mot juste vraiment oui
cette chercheuse en chimie de 53 ans a
dédié sa vie au plastique vert une
aventure dans laquelle elle a été
entraînée il y a 20 ans par un homme un
visionnaire
cet homme c'est Raul Gardini un business
manitalien nous sommes en 1989 à
l'époque il dirige l'un des géants
mondiaux de la grosse chimie cette
année-là il décide de créer novamons car
il a une intuition il est persuadé qu'un
bouleversement économique et écologique
majeur va se produire dans les années à
venir bac ça veut dire qu'il avait prévu
la fin du pétrole
non seulement il a anticipé l'après
pétrole mais pour lui il fallait
carrément inventer des nouvelles
matières premières c'est ça sa vision du
monde
mais pourquoi a-t-il eu cette idée avant
tout le monde en plus
on utilise les produits très peu de
temps et on les jette c'est comme ça
qu'on détruit la planète on a de moins
en moins de ressources
et de plus en plus de déchets
c'est pour faire face à ce défi qu'en
1989 katia est embauché par Raoul
Gardini cette jeune universitaire est
alors chargée de mettre en œuvre une
idée révolutionnaire créer des
plastiques non pas à base de pétrole
mais à base de végétaux et voici
aujourd'hui le résultat des objets en
bioplastiques fabriqués grâce à nos
amons des pailles des gobelets des
cache-pots des couverts des sacs bref
des produits de la vie de tous les jours
Luigi capuzzi et le directeur de
recherche de l'entreprise ce plastique
vert il le développe grâce à une
ressource totalement renouvelable le
maïs du maïs on a extrait cette poudre
blanche
ça c'est de l'amidon de maïs
ça veut dire que le maïs a été
transformé alors
c'est un produit complexe s'il y a des
éléments qu'on peut extraire du maïs
mais c'est comestible ça on peut en
manger
la nourriture
les équipes de Luigi capuzzi mélange cet
amidon de maïs à de l'huile de tournesol
il sera modifié pour donner cette espèce
de spaghetti qui sera ensuite découpée
en milliers de grains ce sont ces grains
qui permettront à des industriels de
fabriquer des produits biodégradables
mais si tout le monde se met à consommer
des bioclastiques toute la question est
de savoir si on ne risque pas de manquer
de maïs pour notre consommation
alimentaire
mais si vous remplacez le pétrole par le
maïs vous allez affamer des gens d'un
bout à l'autre de la planète
on utilise qu'une partie d'un produit
qui sert déjà dans l'industrie
et pour le futur on fait déjà des
recherches pour utiliser le non
seulement l'amidon mais aussi des fibres
des résidus de maïs
[Musique]
donc vous pourriez utiliser des déchets
du maïs c'est ça oui les déchets de maïs
mais aussi d'autres céréales
le principal avantage de cette matière
c'est qu'une fois à l'état de déchets la
nature peut l'absorber très rapidement
et là vous pouvez voir le résultat après
30 jours
[Musique]
au bout de 21 jours les pailles et le
gobelet sont dégradés
en 30 jours leur taille c'est fortement
réduite après 60 jours ils ont quasiment
disparu
et lorsque tous les habitants de la
région jettent leur emballage en
bioplastie à la poubelle le résultat est
encore plus spectaculaire
à une vingtaine de kilomètres de Novara
en pleine campagne une
usine d'un genre particulier
partout ces montagnes de terre noire
pour comprendre leur provenance il faut
revêtir une drôle de combinaison
[Applaudissements]
une combinaison censée protéger les
vêtements de l'odeur pestilentielle qui
règne ici mais qui va encore augmenter
lorsqu'on pénètre dans ce hangar
incroyable à l'intérieur
18000 tonnes de déchets en décomposition
et beaucoup de vapeurs d'eau produite
par cette fermentation une ambiance
lunaire qui n’impressionne pas Francesco
perruccia l'ingénieur à Grenoble qui
dirige le site
ce sont les déchets domestiques de la
cuisine de la nourriture de la
nourriture des légumes des fruits
en plastique là enfin sont des sacs en
plastique ça
ils sont en materbie
des citoyens qui font le tri pour nous
c'est plus facile quand les gens mettent
leurs déchets organiques dans des sacs
biodégradables
ces milliers de ça qu'en materby de chez
novamons les habitants de Novara les ont
utilisés pour y mettre leurs déchets
organiques
il se décomposent en même temps que les
détritus et au bout de trois semaines on
obtient ces montagnes de terres noires
les ordures se sont transformés en
compost qui servira dans l'agriculture
et ça ça va devenir de l'engrais oui
c'est déjà de l'engrais OK
la terre nous offre donc des solutions
pour nos besoins grâce à des ressources
naturelles comme par exemple le maïs
mais le problème c'est que toutes les
ressources ne sont pas renouvelables
certaines deviennent rares comme le
pétrole ou les minerais et on les
exploite toujours plus pour satisfaire
nos besoins de consommation
il faut dire qu'aujourd'hui la plupart
des biens que l'on achète se garde de
moins en moins longtemps le domaine où
c'est le plus frappant ce sont les
produits électroniques
[Musique]
téléviseurs ordinateur appareil photo
des objets sophistiqués parfois fragiles
dont les technologies ne cessent
d'évoluer et les prix de chuter
en cas de panne réparer coûte même
souvent plus cher que de racheter alors
on préfère reprendre du neuf
un renouvellement permanent de produit
qui nous pousse donc à en changer très
souvent et l'objet le plus concerné par
cette tendance est aujourd'hui devenu
indispensable à notre vie quotidienne
il suffit d'un seul geste plus besoin de
clavier il suffit de parler tout ça sur
le smartphone le plus fin du monde
aucun objet n'a aussi vite conquis
l'humanité
en 20 ans intervient sur de cet équipé
et ce n'est pas fini
jusque dans les coins les plus reculés
du globe chacun veut son portable il
s'envan 100 millions
un rythme démentiel qui est loin d'être
anodin car nous avons constaté qu'il
épuise nos ressources naturelles mais
surtout qu'il bouleverse la vie de
population entière
une histoire qui démarre au coin de la
rue
ce jour là marine et Raphaël ont décidé
de changer tous les deux leur téléphone
portable
Isabelle la vendeuse est à la manœuvre
tout de suite elle les oriente vers les
modèles dernier cri des petits bijoux
technologies qui savent tout faire
est-ce que vous c'est la navigation
internet c'est le mail moi j'utilise
énormément le web tout ce qui est
navigation ce sont ces nouvelles
fonctions qui aujourd'hui font craquer
les clients même s'ils sont bien
conscients que les fabricants font tout
pour susciter de nouveaux achats
on va dire qu'il y a des grosses
évolutions toute façon c'est tout bête
on est dans une société de consommation
s'il était évoluent pas on consomme pas
donc de toute façon ils sont obligés
d'évoluer et pour nous pousser à acheter
toujours davantage les opérateurs ont
mis en place un système de subventions
très efficace personne ne paye en fait
son téléphone à son vrai prix son
forfait on est à 459 € à 9 euros et toi
ce sera 129 euros
conséquence de ce système nous changeons
de téléphone tous les 18 mois en moyenne
merci au revoir alors que ces appareils
peuvent durer environ cinq ans un succès
que les fabricants entretiennent
précieusement
la sortie d'un nouveau téléphone est
désormais fêtée comme un événement
extraordinaire
[Musique]
ainsi chaque année 500 nouveaux modèles
sont lancés dans le monde
[Musique]
de petites merveilles qui nécessitent
des dizaines de milliers de pièces et
pour fabriquer chacune de ces pièces on
a dû extraire des matières premières de
la terre
pour se rendre compte de toutes les
ressources qu'il y a à l'intérieur d'un
téléphone il faut aller en région
parisienne à Fontenay-aux-Roses dans les
locaux de Bureau Veritas un géant
mondial de l'expertise technique
ici on teste toutes sortes d'appareils
électroniques pour savoir s'ils sont
dangereux
dans ce labo par exemple on mesure
l'effet des ondes émises par les
portables sur notre cerveau
mais on évalue aussi l'impact du
téléphone sur l'environnement
c'est le travail d'un expert Xavier
vital
[Musique]
il connaît le secret de chaque matière
première contenue dans nos mobiles pour
nous montrer les éléments naturels qu'il
y a à l'intérieur il doit plonger dans
les entrailles de la machine des
montages alors dans ce téléphone on va
donc si on continue à l'ouvrir à rentrer
à l'intérieur on va retrouver de
l'électronique une carte électronique
qui contient des composants et qui va
contenir elle-même un certain nombre de
substances mais des substances
naturelles vous voulez dire on va
retrouver de l'étain de l'or de l'argent
du cuivre qui sont des ressources
naturelles qu'on va prélever dans la
nature on les exploite dans des mines et
on va les transformer pour accomplir un
certain nombre de fonctions sans
lesquelles votre téléphone pourrait pas
marcher ça ne fonctionnerait pas sans
les éléments qu'on va trouver dans la
nature
par exemple ce liseret jaune c'est de
l'or quelques mg indispensables pour
assurer les connexions
et des matières premières qui viennent
du sous-sol de la Terre le portable en
contient des dizaines d'autres comme du
cuivre ou de l'argent
mais l'une des matières les plus
utilisées ont la connais tous c'est
l'étain
tous les petits points blancs absolument
ce sont des points de soudure qui
contiennent une grande partie des temps
le point de soudure il permet de faire
un contact électrique donc l'état sert à
y conduit l'électricité et il permet de
relier chaque composant entre eux dans
le circuit il y a combien de composants
on peut en avoir 500 par téléphone
mobile l'étain jusque là on s'en servait
surtout pour des produits courants comme
la vaisselle ou les boîtes de conserve
mais depuis 20 ans notre consommation
d'ordinateurs et de téléphone a fait
exploser la demande résultat on en
extrait deux fois plus qu'il y a 10 ans
hors de l'étain aujourd'hui une dizaine
de pays seulement en extrait dans le
monde comme la Chine l'Indonésie ou le
Pérou qui sont les plus gros producteurs
mais celui qui suscite le plus de
convoitises se trouve en Afrique la
République démocratique du Congo en
particulier la province du Kivu à l'est
du pays
[Musique]
car c'est dans cette région du monde que
ce minerai est le moins cher à extraire
[Musique]
le Kivu est l'une des régions les moins
accessibles du globe
de part et d'autre des pistes cabossées
s'étale des paysages grandioses
[Musique]
des montagnes à perte de vue
des lacs majestueux au pied des volcans
dans le qui vous on trouve surtout l'un
des sous-sols les plus riches de notre
planète ici la terre regorge d'une
dizaine de minerais vitaux pour nous
portables de l'or du cuivre et notamment
de l'étain
[Musique]
avec la demande mondiale toujours plus
forte la région est devenue une
gigantesque zone minière qui fait vivre
2 millions de personnes
et c'est précisément dans ces mines
d'états que nous voulons aller pour
notre enquête
mais y accéder ne va pas être une mince
affaire car toutes ces richesses ont
transformé la région en poudrière
des bandes armées se livrent une guerre
sans merci pour faire main basse sur ses
précieux minerais
elle contrôle des dizaines de mines à
travers la région
[Musique]
sur notre chemin nous sommes rapidement
arrêtés par un barrage militaire
il s'agit de l'armée régulière du Congo
qui est en opération
fusil mitrailleur lance-roquette ses
soldats partent à l'assaut des rebelles
leur objectif reconquérir les mines
perdues et leur matière première
l'homme qui dirige ses opérations et
justement installée dans le village pour
quelques jours
nous voulons le rencontrer pour en
savoir plus sur les combats dans la
région
ne vous fiez pas aux apparences dans ce
fauteuil cet homme en civil est un
colonel son nom innocent le colonel
innocent il est à la tête d'un régiment
d'une centaine d'hommes armés jusqu'aux
dents
nous on a une mission c'est de tout
faire pour chasser les rebelles de
toutes les mines
mais pourquoi les mines sont-elles si
importantes pour ces groupes armés
et bien parce que c'est leur unique
source de financement et dès qu'ils
seront chassés de toutes ces mines ils
n'auront plus d'argent et ils ne
pourront plus lutter
ces affrontements entre militaires
congolais et groupes armés déchirent la
région depuis une quinzaine d'années
ils sont l'héritage d'un génocide qui a
eu lieu en 1994 juste à côté d'ici au
Rwanda
une guerre qui a fini par déborder au
Congo et surtout au qui vous des
millions de civils rwandais si son
réfugiés mais aussi des militaires
enfuites qui s'y sont installés en
semant la terreur
[Applaudissements]
bilan près de 6 millions de morts le
conflit le plus meurtrier depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale
cette guerre est officiellement terminée
depuis 7 ans mais la zone est encore
très instable
c'est ce qui nous frappe immédiatement
quand nous arrivons à Goma la grande
ville de la région
Goma est aujourd'hui sous contrôle des
casques bleus il y en a 20 000 dans tout
le qui vous le plus gros contingent au
monde des Nations Unies
[Musique]
pour s'approcher des gisements
impossible d'utiliser notre voiture il
faut prendre un hélicoptère des Nations
Unies
[Musique]
car entre Goma et la région des mines il
y a 300 km sans route au-dessus d'une
zone à risque
direction l'ouest du
en survolant ce territoire peu à peu les
vastes étendues cèdent la place à une
végétation de plus en plus dense
c'est dans le sous-sol de cette jungle
que repose ces fameux minerais
indispensables pour nos téléphones
au total 200 gisements dispersés dans
cette forêt vierge
après une heure de vol nous arrivons à
wali
l'hélicoptère des Nations Unies n'ira
pas plus loin ici commence la zone des
mines
et le lendemain matin démarre pour nous
une épreuve une marge de 50 km à travers
la jungle pour rejoindre les mines des
tins avant la nuit 2 3 4 5
pour réussir cette marche dans les temps
il nous faut des porteurs pour notre
matériel de tournage
mais aussi des hommes des scores en cas
d'embuscade par les rebelles
au total un équipage d'une vingtaine de
personnes
nous pénétrons dans la forêt tropicale
très vite la chaleur l'humidité
une vingtaine de collines escarpées à
gravir et à dévaler sur un sentier
accidenté
pour parcourir les 50 km qui nous
séparent des mines nous devons avancer à
Marc forcée
pas question de dormir dans la forêt
trop risqué selon notre escort
après 12 heures de marche nous arrivons
enfin dans un village en plein cœur de
la jungle
le village de bissier ici on a trouvé de
l'État il y a 10 ans un des plus grands
gisements du pays
[Musique]
et depuis ce village est devenu un
centre minier important il s'est
construit à la hâte comme au temps de la
ruée vers l'or
un village qui ressemble à un bidonville
fait de briquet de broc
ou chaque objet a été acheminé à dos
d'homme par le sentier que nous avons
suivi
même ses poissons séchés viennent d'un
lac à 300 km d'ici
quand nous arrivons sur la place
principale le village est en ébullition
tous les mineurs ont été convoqués à une
réunion publique
l'homme qui a rendu la foule et
l'équivalent du sous-préfet anatoma bah
espionner n'a contre nous il a fait 12
heures de marche pour arriver jusqu'ici
et rappeler une consigne à tous les
mineurs
le grand point alors le grand point
la mesure du président est valable
jusqu'à nouvel ordre jusqu'à nouvel
ordre que ce soit clair pas
d'exploitation ni de commercialisation
des minerais sinon que c'est la prison
en clair l'État congolais interdit toute
extraction de minerai au Kivoo une
décision brutale qui fait suite à une
prise de conscience à l'autre bout de la
planète c'était il y a six mois
[Musique]
c'est un endroit où les femmes préfèrent
dormir dans la forêt de peur que les
violeurs ne reviennent la représentante
des Nations Unies a recueilli au qui
vous des témoignages très éprouvants
ils m'ont attrapé par le bras ils m'ont
retiré mon bébé ils étaient 8 à me
violer je leur criais arrêté arrêtez je
meurs
comme cet habitante des dizaines de
milliers de femmes ont été violées ou
qui vous toutes victimes des hommes en
armes qui font régner la terreur pour
s'emparer des précieux minerais
il viole et il pire tous les mineurs
sont rackettés
pour les rebelles comme pour les
militaires les minerais c'est le trésor
de guerre
un scandale qui émet la communauté
internationale
les médias parlent désormais de 100 dans
nos portables
alors face à ce scandale l'été dernier
les États-Unis prennent une mesure
le président Obama signe une loi elle
interdit aux entreprises américaines
l'usage des minerais vendu par les
groupes armés du kivou
sous la pression le président du Congo
n'a plus le choix Joseph Kabila doit
prendre une décision radicale en
septembre dernier il sera la tribune des
Nations Unies le groupe peut armés qui
se nourrissent de l'exploitation
illégale de matière première ce jour-là
il s'engage officiellement à mettre fin
au commerce des minerais de la honte
pour faire face à cette situation
inacceptable
mais sur le terrain cette interdiction
n'est pas du tout la bienvenue
car les minerais sont la seule source de
revenus pour les villageois de bissier
et au moment de notre arrivée cela fait
déjà plusieurs semaines que les mineurs
ne peuvent plus creuser
c'est difficile depuis que les minions
étaient fermés la vie
c'est la misère on s'en sort plus
partout
les mines c'est le seul boulot dans le
coin c'est ce qu'on peut faire d'autre
officiellement plus personne ne creuse à
cause des militaires mais quand on
s'éloigne en poussant l'enquête nous
apprenons que certains s'aventurent
quand même dans les mines malgré
l'interdiction un sujet qui reste très
sensible ici
du gouvernement et de l'armée oui la
représailles peut être terrible torture
fouet
à manger ça c'est comme ça que on traite
les gens qui bravent les mesures oui
nous arrivons à prendre contact avec des
mineurs clandestins
il nous donne un rendez-vous secret sur
la zone des mines pour les retrouver
nous devons escalader une pente très
raide celle que grimpe les porteurs de
minerais
on va jusqu'où ici là-bas c'est là où il
y a les creuseurs voici les mines à flan
de colline le versant est troué comme un
gruyère par les entrées de tunnel
tous les sites ici sont des tunnels
il y a des centaines même des centaines
de 300 et plus
c'est devant l'un de ces tunnels que
nous rencontrons les mineurs clandestins
pour leur sécurité ils resteront
anonymes
ça fait longtemps que vous êtes à
l'intérieur là
on
peut aller voir
[Musique]
tout ici a été creusé à la main
des boyaux très étroits
ou un homme ne tient pas debout
on respire à peine
la chaleur y est plus intense encore que
dehors il fait 40 degrés l'humidité
suffocante
tu peux lui demander d'attendre
oui
il y a des galeries qui descendent à
plus de 300 mètres de profondeur alors
faites gaffe ici parce que c'est
dangereux ça peut s'écrouler c'est pour
ça qu'on met des rondins pour que ça
tienne le coup
précaires les éboulements fréquents
des dizaines d'hommes ont perdu la vie
dans ces galeries
cette pierre sombre c'est de la cité
rite le nom du minerai brut qui donnera
un métal l'étain
s le kilo combien de kilos vous creusez
chaque jour voici
50 ça dépend mais au moins 100 kg
avec 100 kg ce jour-là il y en a pour
300 dollars de pierre dans ces sacs un
an de salaire ailleurs dans le pays mais
toute cette somme n'ira pas dans sa
poche car d’ordinaire il se fait
racketter dès la sortie de la mine
des corps monte il faut qu'on paye un
Bacchi chaud militaire qui sont là-haut
combien
de minerais et après il va y avoir une
barrière puis encore plein d'autres
après
et à chaque fois il y aura encore des
back chiches à payer aux militaires à
chaque barrière
[Musique]
au total la somme reversée peut s'élever
jusqu'à 30% de sa recette mais en ce
moment même en payant il n'est pas sûr
de pouvoir compter sur les militaires
corrompus avec l'interdiction en cours
certains pourraient tout de même
l'empêcher de creuser alors il doit
rester le plus discret possible
lorsqu'il va dans la mine si pour
échapper aux militaires
et vous avez pas peur d'être pris par
les par les militaires là bah oui on a
peur c'est pour ça qu'on vient souvent
la nuit pour ne pas être opéré
pour creuser ce jour là il y avait trois
mineurs dans ce tunnel combien d'autres
creusent comme eux en cachette ou qui
vous difficile de le savoir mais une
chose est sûre l'extraction et le
commerce continue malgré l'interdiction
officielle
et une fois sorti des frontières du
Congo
l'étain de nos portables suit toujours
le même trajet
il traverse l'Afrique par camion pour
être chargé dans les ports de l'océan
Indien
de là le minerai part pour les fonderies
principalement en Asie
l'étain du Congo est alors mélangé à de
l'étain d'autres origines
toutes traces de sa provenance est
perdue
enfin les lingots de métal seront livrés
aux usines de composants électroniques
une longue chaîne qui rend la
traçabilité du métal très compliquée
c'est le revers de la mondialisation
résultat les grandes marques de portable
tentent aujourd'hui de faire pression
sur leur fournisseurs pour supprimer les
minerais du Congo de leur téléphone
mais aucune ne peut le garantir à 100%
Steve Jobs lui-même le créateur de
l'iPhone le reconnaît
nous demandons à nos fournisseurs de
certifié par écrit qu'il n'utilise pas
de minerai de conflit
mais honnêtement il n'y a aucun moyen
d'en être sûr
à chaque nouveau portable acheté il faut
donc toujours plus de matière première
qui risque de financer des guerres ou
d'épuiser la planète alors comment nous
consommateurs pouvons-nous sortir de ce
cycle infernal quelle solution
avons-nous pour changer de téléphone
sans nuire à l'environnement
pour le savoir il faut commencer par
retourner en boutique
depuis un an on peut choisir son
téléphone en se penchant sur des
étiquettes une nouvelle mention indique
la performance environnementale les
téléphones sont notés de 1 à 5 un
affichage plutôt mystérieux que nous
voulons comprendre
nous retournons chez notre expert en
impact écologique
ce qu'il regarde en premier c'est la
façon dont notre téléphone a été
produite car c'est lors de cette étape
qu'il pollue le plus
en moyenne 70% des impacts
environnementaux d'un téléphone mobile
sont liés à sa fabrication
à chaque stade de sa vie notre téléphone
va ainsi être noté sur plusieurs
critères il y a ceux qu'on connaît bien
comme le taux de CO2 ce modèle par
exemple a rejeté 16 kg de gaz à effet de
serre ça veut dire que en termes de
climat il y a 16 kg de gaz carbonique
qui ont été rejetés dans l'atmosphère
pour fabriquer ce produit absolument
pour vous donner un ordre de grandeur un
téléphone mobile qui ne fait que
téléphone mobile donc un téléphone
simple va avoir une empreinte carbone
entre 6 et 10 kg de CO2 un smartphone on
va monter aux alentours de 50 kg de CO2
ah oui donc la moyenne on a aux
alentours de 23 25 kg de CE1 donc
celui-là a plutôt un impact écologique
modeste exactement
impact sur le climat quantité d'eau
utilisée tout compte dans la note du
téléphone il y a même un critère plus
surprenant les ressources
ces matières qui s'épuisent à cause de
notre surconsommation comme l'étain que
nous avons vu en Afrique
une ressource naturelle qui n'est pas
renouvelable un minerai un minerais on
estime qu'à peu près 6000 à 6 millions
de tonnes d'états disponibles dans les
stocks et dans ces 6 millions de tonnes
on prélève à peu près chaque année
300000 tonnes pardon ce qui fait qu'à
peu près entendre source détente
disponible dans 20 ans au rythme de
consommation actuel et dans l'état des
connaissances des stocks actuels il y en
aura plus et pourtant on pourrait
facilement éviter d'épuiser la planète
voici ce qui pourrait devenir les
nouveaux gisements de minerai ces
téléphones sont de vieux modèles et ils
contiennent des matières premières que
l'on pourrait récupérer
généralement nos anciens portables
restent au fond de nos tiroirs et
pourtant certains sont prêts à nous les
racheter
nous retrouvons marine et Raphaël leur
nouveau téléphone en poche il leur reste
maintenant à un cas sérieux à régler que
faire des anciens
voici les modèles dont ils veulent se
débarrasser ils viennent s'ajouter à une
collection de plus vieux téléphone qui
traîne dans les tiroirs en France deux
portables sur 3 finissent ainsi leur vie
au placards un gâchis pour la planète
mais aussi pour le portefeuille car il y
a mieux à faire il suffit d'un tout
petit tour sur le net pour s'en
convaincre
pas mal de sites ils sont une dizaine
sur ce créneau des sites qui vous
proposent de l'argent en échange de
votre vieux mobile
50 euros
et chez eux
des sites qui font même de la surenchère
entre eux
68 ans
les prix varient en fonction du modèle
de l'âge et de l'état et à ce jeu-là
c'est l'ancien téléphone de marine qui
est gagnant comme neuf 82 euros
80 euros alors que je l'ai payé 39
29 avec les offres forfaits etc donc
mini de l'argent dessus leur vieux
portable racheté plus cher qu'il ne leur
ont coûté Raphaël et Marine n'en
reviennent pas ils n'ont pas idée de la
deuxième vie qui les attend
quelque part dans la banlieue de l'île
c'est ici que chaque matin arrive des
centaines de téléphones portables
envoyés des quatre coins de France et
d'Europe
nous sommes chez phoenbach l'un des plus
gros récupérateurs du secteur la société
akirafal et Marine ont envoyé leurs
anciens appareils
toute la journée Sébastien contrôle ses
vieux téléphone et c'est l'ordinateur
qui décide ce qu'il faut en faire
je regarde la marque le modèle la plaque
d'immatriculation du téléphone et là il
me dit est votez donc celui-là il est
encore il va prendre une deuxième vie au
niveau scientifique il est correct et
encore au goût du jour 9 téléphones sur
10 qui arrivent ici seront revendus sur
le marché de l'occasion en France ou à
l'étranger
parmi les grossistes qui viennent se
fournir régulièrement Charles un
camerounais et ce qu'il cherche ce ne
sont pas forcément les modèles les plus
sophistiqués
alors j'en ai besoin également ce modèle
si je l'achète à chaque fois que je peux
venir ici c'est l'un des téléphones les
plus vendu au monde qu'est-ce qu'il a de
particulier c'est que particulier sa
robustesse
il tombe
alors
on le remonte et il fonctionne
impeccablement
par rapport aux autres
ce jour-là Charles va acheter 300
téléphones qui vont repartir en Afrique
et resservir ce sont autant d'appareils
neufs en moins à fabriquer en exploitant
des matières premières mais tous ne
connaîtront pas le même sort
celui-ci par exemple sera recyclé alors
celui-là il a moins une bonne quinzaine
d'années
[Musique]
on voit ça encore les les grosses
batteries
et pourtant il marche peut-être encore
et peut-être qu'ils fonctionnent encore
mais plus personne n'est plus personne
n'en veut ça n'intéresse plus personne
celui-là il va être il va être broyer
tous ces déchets vont donc repartir en
usine pour être cyclées un processus
très complexe qui va permettre de
séparer les différents métaux et de
récupérer au final les matières
précieuses que nos portables contiennent
de l'or de l'argent du platine de
l'étain ou du palladium presque tout ce
que contient un téléphone et recyclable
si chacun d'entre nous ramenait ses
vieux mobiles pour les recycler on
pourrait récupérer ainsi 240
000 tonnes de matières premières au lieu
d'aller les chercher dans le sous-sol de
notre planète
[Musique]
nous voici arrivés au terme de notre
voyage
une enquête qui nous a permis de
découvrir les effets de notre
hyperconsommation
des effets dont imaginions pas l'ampleur
chacun d'entre nous consomme quatre fois
plus qu'il y a 60 ans et achète des
produits toujours plus jetables
un mode de vie qui met notre avenir au
défi celui de trouver des solutions dès
aujourd'hui et nous avons tous le
pouvoir d'agir
on peut acheter des vêtements plus
respectueux de l'environnement la
plupart des grandes marques ont lancé de
nouvelles lignes écolo l'un
orties mais surtout coton bio elle
prévoit de multiplier leurs ventes par 3
d'ici 5 ans
les industriels du plastique eux ont
décidé de fabriquer 10% de leurs
produits en matière végétale d'ici 2015
actuellement chez nous moins d'un
téléphone sur 10 et recyclés mais d'ici
5 ans on estime que cela concernera un
tiers de nos appareils
le recyclage de nos déchets plastiques
ne cesse d'évoluer une dizaine d'usine
capable de changer nos vieux sacs et
emballages en carburant sont déjà en
projet en Europe
[Musique]
achetez mieux et de façon plus
responsable
gardez plus longtemps nos produits et
recycler davantage
[Musique]
un mode de vie qui s'impose aujourd'hui
car au rythme où nous puisons dans nos
ressources naturelles il nous faudra
deux planètes d'ici 20 ans pour assouvir
notre soif de consommation
or nous n'avons qu'une terre
[Musique]